so we're excited about the many saints
of newark and we hope it's good we know
several people that will really kill
themselves if it's not good that's true
they're seeing it the first day it comes
out
uh people get really excited about these
things that's that's a big part of their
life
like i was in new york with people and
they went this is where they film the
sopranos like that's the entire way they
interface with the world is a show
and i love the sopranos i think it's
probably the greatest show ever made but
i haven't you know re-watched it 17
times
and i'm not going to see you know i
didn't buy my tickets six months ago to
see the many saints you knew it for the
first day but i understand that people
do it's like that irishman movie where
people were really overly invested
you know it's enough already to me i
think it's enough i think it's overkill
i haven't even seen the movie and i'm
gonna go out and just say already like i
didn't need the prequel yeah to tony
soprano's life i just didn't care it
didn't mean anything to me i thought it
was a brilliant piece of art we don't
need to make more of it than what it was
right we don't it's not a philosophy of
life i don't think or it shouldn't be
i don't think we need that i think we
need to just enjoy it for what it is
which is great art and then move away
step away
we don't need to get to soprano's
cookbook we don't need to you know talk
about feach lamanna we don't need to do
any of that we don't need to start going
through
the episodes that have changed our lives
i think we just really need to move on
but again it's you know people are
putting a little too much
into it in my opinion but i could be
wrong maybe it's the greatest film
that's ever been made james gandolfini's
son is in it why i don't know
and philip seymour hoffman's son is now
in things licorice pizza what do we call
thomas anderson why why are we putting
it they're [ __ ] to children why in
gods it makes me hate the legends that
died that we're giving your kid aren't
these people the same people that talk
about how unfair everything is and
inequality and they're always voting for
democrats because they're going to fix
the inequality and there's so many
concentrations of wealth and all they do
is is [ __ ] give dead people's kids
jobs that are already rich christ
almighty enough they're already [ __ ]
rich he's not a genius philip seymour
topman's sons not a genius his name is
[ __ ] cooper he's clearly not a genius
genius skips many generations okay like
all of them god forbid we get an actor
who's been in [ __ ] the grind for
years sleeping on a [ __ ] floor trying
to get this job who may be the next
philip seymour hoffman maybe let's do
that
okay what do you how do you cast things
now ancestry.com
this is absurd it's stupid and
disgusting all the things you people
pretend to care about you don't it's
just a cheap [ __ ] trick to get people
out to the [ __ ] movies well how about
make a good [ __ ] movie instead of
using these cheap [ __ ] tricks
okay
i have no beef with gandolfini's son and
i have no beef with
cooper hoffman or whatever but jesus
christ already why are we doing this
they're not the best candidates it's
absolutely impossible that they are the
best candidates for the job there's no
[ __ ] way
they're gonna keep doing this
they're just gonna keep giving roles to
children whose parents are legends
who've died
here's what i love about stand-up comedy
i know i won't mention names there are
legends whose children do stand-up
comedy no one cares about them and
that's so important because it is kind
of a little bit of a meritocracy isn't
it yeah isn't it
i mean so what's going on and i've had a
little i've been enough with paul thomas
anderson too you freak wait no he's the
genius who have i had enough with
moonrise kingdom oh wes anderson i've
had enough with him i've just had enough
with him and i like a lot of what he's
done
paul thomas anderson i like a lot i know
that's your favorite director yeah he's
great he is great wes anderson i've had
enough with you he's put chalamet in the
new one yeah i'm kind of sick of it
chalamet stop ruining everything you do
he really is man he's ruining everything
this is the new one it's like you know
it's bill murray francis mcdormand the
whole thing but then timothy is is kind
of the star of this one oh god get me
out of here please this life is it's
called the french dispatch here it is of
course it is you just look at look at
his face he just that's good it's called
one you know what i call that one black
actor
that's what i call it
i don't call it the french dispatch i
call it more of the same
it's free you know go go
i want christopher gas to cast a movie
with fred willard's son
you know
everybody's you know and this is
hollywood everybody's like no it's
concentrations of wealth and family
money and
listen wes anderson's great and maybe
this movie will be good i'm i'm a little
sick of
chalamet
i'm just sick of it yeah can't we have
something else
can we have something else other than
this twink who doesn't age
this pixie who does not age that must
prance through every [ __ ] movie
that's ever been made
is there anything else that's all
is there anyone else that can do this
job
please
and not hansel and gretel elgort not him
either can we get someone else please
someone else other than timothy chalamet
what about cooper hoffman
what does cooper hoffman look like i'll
show you
this is uh that's him as a kid so here's
what he looks like in the movie right
here
he kind of looks like phillips hoffman
and boogie nights just kind of the
so if this isn't offensive why am i
supposed to be offended that uh like
jamie dimon's kid has money
right so when somebody at goldman sachs
gives a job to their son why is that
supposed to offend me you frauds why is
that supposed to offend me if this
doesn't offend me or shouldn't it all
offend me
i guess technically yeah one of the kids
that got hired on snl's dad's like a
producer at snl i don't really care
about that and i even tweeted like
enough ready because the kid's funny the
kid is funny and if i see these movies
and these guys are really good in it
i'll still say [ __ ] them because it
still should have went to
you know one of these other people i'd
end up hating
but
one of the kids got snl i forget you
know one of those strange looking kids
from
the world works the guy with the dad
gets the job and the kid's funny and
their sketch group's funny i mean they
probably hate me or whatever you know
it's like logical and brilliant but
um
i just don't care
like if i i'm just saying let's not care
at all like don't [ __ ] ever come to
me and start talking about like finance
families then
stop with this [ __ ] just cut it out
immediately if you're gonna do this and
hollywood seems like they're gonna do
this if we're just going to as a as a
gimmick give roles to dead people's kids
then i don't want to hear [ __ ]
about [ __ ]
the presidency of george w bush
remember that when bush was the thing
that was an entire narrative of like how
would you let this god right i'm sure
this guy's a nice guy michael gandolfini
i'm sure he's lovely i don't know like a
nice kid i don't know i don't care
take your money and get out of here
can anyone take their goddamn money and
leave please
is anything ever enough
for christ
anything
how many generate like what let it go
we didn't need this [ __ ] movie
the many saints in newark
we didn't need it yeah we didn't need el
camino either the breaking bad one with
jesse pink we did not need that i didn't
even i didn't even dignify that but with
even like
letting it hold any space in my head we
do not need that who's that actor uh
aaron paul we do not need more of him
we do not need that
we do not need la brea and then one of
the kids in lebron i think is a sweet
kid but you you have to be homeless and
the show has to be cancelled
sorry
the jack kid oh jack martin yeah he's a
nice kid i've met him you know he's an
actor in l.a but
he's not a bad actor probably but the
show is atrocious and i believe it
should be cancelled and that he should
have to work it like astro burger for a
year to pay for what he's done yeah
to just flip a few
put a few
put a mayo in a bun
make a nice burger to pay for what
you've done to us with this show
where people fall in a hole
i
you know
and why should he have a chance let
somebody let some some dead guys kid do
it
why have a new actor do it let's have a
debt let's have someone who died
let's have their kid do it
that's all
that seems to make sense you know
one exception is michael k williams son
michael k williams i don't know if he
has a son but maybe if he has a son he
could do something okay that's my one
exception
oh yeah that would be cool that might be
cool that's one exception
it rarely doesn't skip a generation you
have like larry mcmurtry james mcmurtry
it's hard to think about listen
princess diana
died right
and what's her son doing over here
wasting everyone's goddamn time
him and his wife were running around
spending millions of dollars on security
okay
i don't know what they're afraid they're
afraid that someone's gonna come near
them and be racist
so they have to spend millions and
millions of dollars going to new york
city hotel she you know she spent 75k on
the on the baby shower at the
presidential suite at the mark you're
sitting there eating caviar and
they are running around here so i just
just stopped talking about fairness and
inequality and the death tax and all
this [ __ ] like
stop this please stop it please